KOH KIM: Whoa, showtime.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
All right, so I'm Dan Galpin,
and I'm a developer advocate
with Android Games.
And with--
KOH KIM: And I'm--
DAN GALPIN: With me is--
KOH KIM: With me.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm Koh Kim.
I'm part of the Google Play
business development team
focused on games.
(IN UNISON): And we're here to
level up your Android game!
DAN GALPIN: Oh yeah.
So thank you for joining
us at the very last
session of the day here.
We'll hopefully keep you awake
until the big party.
So we get a lot of
questions, OK?
And let's go over those first.
You can hear actually--
I think they're rehearsing next
door, that loud nose.
KOH KIM: So how I
get discovered?
Is one question.
DAN GALPIN: How do
I get featured?
KOH KIM: How do I
get five stars?
DAN GALPIN: How do I get
rid of bad ratings?
KOH KIM: How do I make
users play my game?
DAN GALPIN: How do I make
users buy stuff?
KOH KIM: And that a
lot of questions.
DAN GALPIN: But sometimes
these questions miss a
fundamental point.
And at that point,
in the center of
everything, there is a user.
KOH KIM: And we like users.
I mean, they're fascinating.
DAN GALPIN: Baffling.
KOH KIM: They may be quite
baffling creatures.
DAN GALPIN: So instead of
trying to answer those
questions up there, we're
focused on what's really
important, which is that guy.
KOH KIM: And we'll give you
our not-so-secret formula.
And it's all about what the
odds are, how do you make
money, or basically help you
increase the probability of
getting featured
on Google Play.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
Happy users, more users--
that's the way you're ultimately
going to be
successful.
So let's start by covering
what you already know.
OK, last year, we came out
here-- actually Ian and I came
out here last year.
And Ian's mysteriously
vanished and
been replaced by Koh.
KOH KIM: Sorry.
He was abducted by aliens, and
they've performed some
experiments, and out came me.
DAN GALPIN: And we talked about
something we were very
excited about, 10 things game
developers should know.
And the great thing is between
last year and this year, we've
actually taken those things
and we've codified them.
We put them up on
developer.android.com.
In fact, I could stop right
here and just say click
Distribute and click
App Quality.
OK?
It's super, super important,
and here's why.
Because there's a lot of things
game developers are
still getting wrong, and this
means that our QA team has to
spend more time reviewing stuff,
sending cycles back to
developers, saying, please
change this or
please change that.
So an example is navigation.
We've been telling developers
for years, make sure the Back
button works.
Don't put on-screen
prompts on there.
But people still do it.
And not only that, if you don't
support the Back button,
it leads to bad reviews.
Users say, wait.
They click, and they
click, and they
click, and nothing happens.
They're like, I don't
understand.
I've been trained by every other
app to do this, and it
doesn't work.
And so that's very important.
There's also other buttons
on the phone.
Make sure the volume
controls work.
That's something some
people still miss.
And also, our QA team really
hates seeing that vestigial
Menu button there
at the bottom.
They'll say, no, no,
take it away.
And it's really, really
easy to take away.
You just say, I'm going to use
the latest version of Android.
And that's really cool
for a lot of reasons.
One, it means you're actually
testing on the latest version
of Android, which
is really cool.
We like that.
And two, it actually means
that that Menu
button will go away.
So get rid of it.
If you really, really want to
have it there, make sure that
it has a really important
function.
But you'll still have to explain
to our review team why
you really need to have
it there in your game.
All right, so let's go
to our next topic
everyone gets wrong--
notifications.
KOH KIM: Oh, geez.
DAN GALPIN: Spammy notifications
are really,
really awful.
And I'm not even going to put
up an example here, because
everyone knows this.
Notifications should not be
something that's an ad for
something else, OK?
Notification should be
something that are
controllable by the user.
In fact, the best thing you can
do is make it-- if you're
going to do a lot of
notifications--
give the user precise control.
Say, you know what?
I don't want a notification
between the hours
that I might be asleep.
Cool?
KOH KIM: Or when you're in an
important meeting, or when--
I don't know--
sometimes, when you're
on a date.
When you hear the whole bing--
DAN GALPIN: Well not, only that,
a lot of notifications
say, you know what?
I'm going to play a
custom sound, OK?
Well, I want my notifications
from things that are really
important to play sounds, and
from games actually just make
it a little bit quieter.
Otherwise, I'm going to turn
them off in the OS, because
now we allow support for that.
So it actually helps you
out to do this as well.
And you'll get bad reviews.
OK.
Last year, we talked about all
the things that you shouldn't
ask for in terms of
permissions, OK?
You are a game, OK?
You are not an operating system,
and there's a really,
really good chance that
you don't need to
know the user's bookmarks.
You don't need to know things
like their fine location.
Unless you are a location-based
game and you
need to know the user is
standing right here, use
coarse location.
You shouldn't actually
have to--
KOH KIM: Like call
phone number?
That's kind of creepy.
DAN GALPIN: You can use Intent
to call phone numbers, OK, if
you really, really need to.
You don't need a permission to
actually-- why would you
directly call them, OK?
Displaying system
level alerts.
Unless you absolutely need to
display something on the
screen when you're not running,
and you have to
justify that to our review team,
you're never going to
get featured if you have some
of these bad permissions.
And then finally, SMS is just
awful, because you can
actually bill the user for
things without them knowing it
potentially.
So don't do it.
KOH KIM: Who uses SMS
anymore, really?
I use Hangouts all the
time, perfectly fine.
DAN GALPIN: Right, exactly.
We've also talked in the past
a lot about audio, OK?
Because audio should not play
when the screen is off.
Audio should not play when
you're on the Home screen.
you're not in the game.
And this is really bad.
Because you're in a business
meeting, and suddenly you're
giving this big presentation.
You've got your suit
on, so clearly you
don't work at Google.
And suddenly, music comes
out of your pants.
And your boss is like, hey, I
know that he's been playing
around with some kiddie games
in his spare time.
So don't do it, OK?
Our review team will
catch these things.
We've actually made it
a lot easier to do
this in Jelly Bean.
But unfortunately, our review
team will still test on those
older devices, so you better
make it work everywhere.
So again, this is a document
that's right online.
I'm just going through the
document and pointing out
important things to note.
StrictMode is cool.
You should test with it.
Our testers will test
with it, OK?
Make sure there aren't big
red flashes conspicuously
throughout your game, OK?
It means that there's a chance
that you're causing the UI
thread to block.
It means that someone's not
going to be able to hit a
button and have it be
responsive in the
middle of your game.
It sucks.
You don't want that, OK?
Finally, your app needs to
provide high-quality graphics
for different form
factors, OK?
This is important, because it
turns out that the devices
that our review team is most
likely to be testing against
are these guys.
And they have three different
form factors,
three different sizes.
And it turns out if you target
these three sizes, you
actually are going to get just
about every important device
that people are spending
money on on Google
Play in terms of coverage.
So these are three very
important classes of devices.
And if you don't have all three
of these, you're going
to have to explain why your
game can't run on
all three of them.
So an example would be
on Nexus 10, OK?
It is a high-DPI device, OK?
A lot of older tablets
weren't.
So if your text is microscopic
and difficult to read and your
buttons require hands that are
meant for an elf, you probably
have to go and think about
how you're scaling.
All right.
And of course, if you want to
get featured, you better think
about your assets.
I'm talking about the
artwork that goes
along with your game.
Now we've changed things a
lot in Google Play, OK?
And we'll go over that in
slightly more detail.
But the important thing is that
you need to have a really
great large icon, because icons
are always important.
They're always the most
important representation of
your brand within the device
and within Google Play.
But now they're more important,
because now they're
the only representation in many
versions of the Play store.
So for example, this icon here?
Great.
It says, I'm going to be
throwing paper into a bucket.
I get exactly what's going on.
It's cool, right?
And that's the way it
appears on a tablet.
And you can put a lot of stuff
into these large icons.
I mean, look.
I've got a brand.
I've got a name.
I know exactly what's
going on here.
So you actually can get quite
creative with it.
It's a little different
from what we were
saying a year ago.
But the best part about all of
these the guidelines is in
addition to the guidelines
themselves, we also give you
an actual test suite that you
can go and hand to your QA.
Let me just explain.
It's not just, make sure your
app does this, but it's a set
of steps to actually go and
verify that your app is really
doing the right thing.
Rotate your device this way.
Click here.
Click the Home button.
Check for this state.
You can actually hand that
to your QA team.
It is actually what our QA
team does when we look at
every single featured
application that goes into
Google Play.
So remember--
KOH KIM: So where was
that again, Dan?
To find everyone.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, yes.
That's a good point.
Here, wait, why don't
you say it?
It'll have more punch
if you say it.
KOH KIM: Sure.
So remember, it's
developer.android.com.
You go to Distribute and
then App Quality.
And let me repeat this.
You should definitely canvass
your QA team or check this,
because this will definitely
increase your probability that
our teams will be like, hey,
this is an awesome game.
We should probably
take a look.
And the fact that you've
actually listened to us and
implemented this in your game
makes us feel really good
about ourselves.
DAN GALPIN: Well, more
importantly, it means you have
a lot less work to do.
Because if you don't implement
this and we love your game,
OK, we're going to have
to come back to you.
And we're going to say, you
have to change this
and this and this.
And then you'll say, well, I
don't really want to change
that, but OK.
And then well, no, you didn't
get to that one.
And then all of a sudden, a
month has passed, and you
realize you could have been
featured a month earlier had
you just done this stuff
to begin with.
So please, look at this stuff.
It's great, and we're going
to keep updating it.
All right.
KOH KIM: So assuming
that you have--
DAN GALPIN: We're now
at level two.
KOH KIM: Right.
We're now in level two, right?
DAN GALPIN: That was all
level one, guys.
KOH KIM: So now we're
in level two.
Like Dan said, he covered all
the things you should be
looking at for your core app
quality guidelines, such as
Back button navigation,
some of the SDKs
and all that stuff.
So let's talk about
doing all of that.
That seems like probably
a lot of work.
So really, why should
you care?
Ultimately, it's about getting
kind of featured and promoted
within the Google Play store.
And I mean, it is a lot
of work, but I'm sure
you guys are like--
DAN GALPIN: I mean, our
editorial teams, right?
Actual people go and
look at your game.
KOH KIM: They're not robots.
I mean, Google is kind of
magical in the one sense, but
our store is not curated
by robots.
DAN GALPIN: Not yet.
KOH KIM: Not yet anyway.
Soon, maybe.
I'm waiting for that "Star
Trek" computer.
Anyway, so why should
you care?
Because yes, our merchandising
team does look at all these
games on a weekly basis.
And we have them all
over the world.
Remember, we're a global market,
so there's games that
could be promoted and featured
all over the place.
So what does that mean?
So getting featured, it
is actually a power
boost for your game.
So let's take an example
of one game that
was released recently.
They were launched on day one.
It's pretty good.
500,000 installed.
DAN GALPIN: That's not bad.
KOH KIM: That's pretty solid
for organic growth.
That's where we all
want to go.
But look at what happens when
it gets featured, right?
Day five.
Remember one week is
a featuring period.
They went from 500K to
almost 3 million by
the end of that week.
DAN GALPIN: And remember, the
game developer did the most
important thing to begin with.
This was a game that was very
highly rated to begin with on
Google Play.
So when we actually did the
featuring period, it just
powered up their game.
If the game is looking bad and
going downhill in terms of the
ratings, and we feature it,
this is not what happens.
So this is about an app having
great quality, and in
addition, getting a boost
through featuring.
KOH KIM: Right.
Featuring doesn't help
bad games, FYI.
DAN GALPIN: Not at all.
It makes it worse.
KOH KIM: Actually, your ratings
will probably take a
nosedive if we feature
a bad game.
DAN GALPIN: From which you
will never recover.
So yeah.
So it's very important that
the game is awesome.
So that's part of the reason we
really put so much time and
effort into making sure
users will like it.
KOH KIM: So let's talk about
some other developers and
their experiences on getting
featured on Google Play and
why it's important.
And so this is a developer,
anonymous.
He said downloads, installs
increased 10 to 20x.
That's pretty good.
I don't know how many of you
played "Super Hexagon."
DAN GALPIN: Yah!
KOH KIM: Yeah, probably the
hardest game alive.
I love hard games, by the way.
Anyway, their sales of their
game has increased by 4x
during feature week.
And I'm sure a lot
of you have known
"Sword & Sorcery," hopefully.
I'm sure we're all game
developers here, right?
Maybe?
OK, so they been on sale
for four months.
During feature week, 55% of
revenue was made during the
feature week, which is a
little scary, actually.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
I'm not sure that's a message I
want to send to developers.
KOH KIM: I don't know if it's
a message, but I mean, it
drives something.
Getting noticed by us
is going to really,
really help your game.
DAN GALPIN: I mean, I think when
you see that number, you
say, all right.
Perhaps there are things outside
of being featured the
developer needed to do.
Because clearly, the
game was awesome.
It monetized really,
really well.
But it just wasn't
getting eyeballs.
KOH KIM: Right.
So point proven.
It's pretty important.
But after you get featured,
now what, right?
Actually, featuring is only
the beginning, right?
I mean, once you get featured,
it's kind of that first step
that opens doors to a lot of
many other promotions.
We've talked about
Editor's Choice.
That gets updated on
a quarterly basis.
We've talked about some of
the top developer badges.
But how do I get
to that point?
I'm sure many of you are
wondering about that.
So I'm going to let Dan talk
about that, on how you can
actually use Google to kind of
increase and kind of like
level up your distribution.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
So we made a little announcement
a few hours ago.
And I've already talked about
it a little bit in another
talk, but let me just go over.
In case you missed it, OK, we
have now launched Play Games
platform services,
which is great.
Because we now have a system
for leaderboards and
achievements and real-time
multiplayer and cloud services
and even an anti-piracy feature,
which I'm really
excited about.
So that games that are premium
titles, that are paid titles
on Google Play, can actually
disable key features to people
who are not registered as
users of that game.
So it's something we think
is really important.
A lot of times, people
think, all right.
We're actually leaning
everything
towards non-premium content.
Actually, we really want to
help premium content be
successful, so we've made it a
very important launch portion
of Play Games platform
services.
But this is only the beginning,
because Play Games
platform services is actually
part of Google+.
So it's got simple
authentication, which is great.
Because people actually prefer
to log in through Google+ than
through a lot of other means,
especially when they're
playing games, as
it turns out.
Interactive posts and
app activities.
Now I'm not going to go through
an entire lecture on
all the ways you can
plusify your game.
But the coolest thing, I think,
is interactive posts,
so that's what I'm going
to talk about.
So when you actually log in to
Play Games services, you get
for free a Google+ enabled
scope, which means you can
automatically start calling
the Google+ APIs.
And this is what it
could look like.
So here is our awesome game,
"Nostalgic Racer."
This is a real game.
We actually use this internally
to test the APIs.
And someday, hopefully, we'll
release it to all of you,
because it's awesome.
And as you see, it's got
a G+ Sign In button.
And you can use our graphics.
Once again, we have a whole
bunch of guidelines for how
you might integrate this
with your game.
And then we get this nice
permission dialog, which has
tons and tons of stuff about
what you're sharing.
It allows you to say, I don't
want the game to know who my
friends are, or I only want the
game to know who certain
friends are, and then I only
want certain friends of mine
to know that I'm playing the
game all sitting there.
But then, even better, we can
create interactive posts.
And these are really,
really cool.
Because right now, I've added
a button in my game saying,
"Challenge me," OK?
And it has already gone and
looked at my circles and said,
hey, these are the guys you have
the most affinity with.
It's actually populated my
circles for me, this
particular post for me, knowing
that these are the
people that I'm most likely
to be challenging.
And it's created a call to
action with this really,
really cool Challenge button.
So it's targeted sharing, and
it's got notification.
This is sounding very salesy,
but it's really cool.
I like this stuff.
KOH KIM: It's kind of cool.
Notice he didn't challenge
me, because he's
afraid I'd beat him.
DAN GALPIN: No way.
I'm challenging Todd.
Although he's really good at the
game, because he actually
wrote an entire version of it.
So I'm probably going to lose.
And actually, Bruno will
complete-- well, I don't know.
All right.
So in any case, this is what
they end up getting
if they're in mobile.
So they end up getting this
fabulous challenge right with
a call to action.
If the game isn't installed,
it'll allow them to install
the game right away, OK?
It can either bring them to
the store, or it can bring
them straight to the game.
And this doesn't just show up
on their mobile device.
This shows up on every Google
property that contains a
Google bar, right there in
that box in the corner.
So this is a very, very
pervasive notification, which
is why it is an interactive
post.
The user actually has
to decide they're
going to send this.
And we have a lot of other verbs
other than challenge.
Challenge is one of the
things we support.
We support things
like gifting.
And these are fully
interactive.
So it cannot just take you back
to launching the game,
but it can actually contain
data that can take you to
launch exactly into the point of
the game that you want, or
actually contain metadata that
could allow you to properly
gift something to someone.
So this is something
that's cool.
It's on top of all of the stuff
we've already done.
So remember, it takes you
directly to the game, or take
you directly to Install.
So we think this can
be a great way of
helping to drive installs.
All right.
Enough with Play services.
Let's talk a little bit about
what's going on in YouTube.
And if you haven't already seen
it, there's a really,
really cool session about
YouTube and games here at
Google I/O, so you should
definitely look it up on the
streaming site.
So a lot of you are already
taking advantage of YouTube
for your market listings,
which is cool.
Everyone should have video in
their market listings for a
lot of reasons.
One is, it turns out, gamers
really like video.
In these rather old statistics,
we can see that
gamers actually found out when
they were looking to buy a
game watching gameplay videos
was the number one way they
said that they were actually
looking to buy games.
Watching trailers
is number two.
And then all these other things
that people spent an
enormous amount of time
working on are
actually much lower.
So gameplay video is
really important.
And one of the cool things we've
now released are ways in
which you can actually share
video directly from your game,
actual gameplay video.
So we actually have an
API now for game
video uploads and playback.
Again, you should really look
at the YouTube stuff.
It's very, very cool.
You can see this is a game that
was built with Unity that
actually allows you to upload
3D graphics from within the
game straight to YouTube.
Very, very slick.
And all the source code, I
believe, is going to be
published for that if
it's not already.
So think about using the
YouTube APIs, OK?
This costs you nothing, OK?
Data uploads, OK?
There's an Android
client library.
It allows you to
make very large
video uploads to YouTube.
And of course, the Android
Player API.
Because realistically, we know
that when you download a game
for Google Play, the larger
the game is, the fewer
downloads you're going to get.
That's just reality.
These guys, they're all on
constrained networks.
They have phones with
limited storage.
So why put in an enormous video
at the beginning of your
game instead of just streaming
it from YouTube?
So not only can you have the
game on YouTube so that every
time someone plays the video
within your game, you actually
get a play within YouTube, which
is kind of cool, but you
don't actually have to download
that video they're
only going to want
to watch once.
There was a company who did this
years and years ago that
made a game about fowl
that were angry.
And very few developers have
actually followed them, but
it's a really, really
good tactic.
And strangely enough, a lot of
developers would love to be as
successful as they've been.
So there's a lot more stuff
to talk about this.
It's at youtube.com/dev.
Look into it.
It's very, very cool.
There's tons of other Google
APIs you might want to take
advantage of, like even Hangouts
APIs and +1 buttons.
You can actually do install
from the web if
you're using +APIs.
.
It's very, very cool, and I
encourage you to look at all
of it at developers.google.com.
All right.
KOH KIM: So the important
part.
DAN GALPIN: Level three.
We made it though
the first two.
KOH KIM: Yes, we made it
through the first two.
So it's all about
making them pay.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, I
think actually
I'm doing this, right.
KOH KIM: I think you're
doing this anyway.
But money is important.
DAN GALPIN: One of the questions
we often get from
developers is, how do I make
money on Android games?
I mean, if you're a developer,
you probably wish there was an
easy command to do that.
But the truth is, it's
not that simple.
To help, we've introduced
In-App Billing v3.
It's easier to implement
reliably.
Let's make that clear.
So here's the basic idea.
In the old version of In-App
Billing, you actually had to
maintain a state machine, which
you had to maintain
across a broadcast
receiver and a
service and your activity.
And if you're using some game
engines, oftentimes that
service was actually running
something that wasn't running
your game engine, so you had
to then provide logic to
connect everything back.
And if you were doing
managed items--
let's say you had a premium
mode of your
game you were selling--
then you also had to provide a
database to store all those
managed items.
And you probably encrypted that,
because you were trying
to be really careful about
making sure that people can't
just easily hack into that.
And all of these things
are things every
developer had to do.
But in Billing v3, we've
actually simplified a lot of
these things.
So you, for example, say, I want
to buy 100 elfberries.
KOH KIM: Elfberries?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
KOH KIM: Really?
DAN GALPIN: Hey, it's fun.
They're blue.
And Google Play responds with
something like, OK.
It's a synchronous API.
It's much, much easier for
people to implement.
Secondly, we now have
local item pricing.
OK, this is something we should
have had from the
beginning, but we have it now.
And it's really, really awesome,
because you now can
actually tell your users how
much you're going to charge
for an item before they actually
go to the Play store.
You can have your entire catalog
sitting there with all
the actual prices that they're
actually going to get charged
before you actually
have to go.
It's really, really
cool, right?
KOH KIM: No, it's cool, because
it's actually important.
Because it doesn't revolve
around America.
So you take $0.99, right?
If you look at Korea or Japan or
Asia, it comes out as this
weird number, like 1,058 won.
DAN GALPIN: And you should
definitely know what that
number is if you're going
to have it in your game.
And you should, of course, fix
it if it is a strange number.
Another thing in v3, as I
mentioned, is restoring
purchases is really,
really cheap.
So it used to be in the old
days, the only way you could
possibly deal with a premium
item would be to actually
store it along with your
games database.
Now with v3, you can query
Google Play as
often as you like.
And that's great, because one
of the most natural times
you'd want to do that is when
you launch the game or when
you come back to the game.
And this also allows you to keep
track very, very easily
of where Google Play's
state is.
So if they even went on another
device, purchased
premium content, you can
immediately sync that up to
your device.
We actually go through and sync
all of that stuff in the
background across all of your
devices so you don't have to.
And of course, as I mentioned
before, it's easier to
implement correctly.
And here's the point.
When a customer decides to put
their trust in you as the game
developer and in us as Google,
this is an incredibly
important singular moment.
Because you have something
very, very valuable.
It's not the $0.99 or percentage
of $0.99 that
you're about to get.
It's their trust.
They gave you their physical
money, and they expect to get
something in return.
I mean, nothing is more valuable
to a developer then
your reputation at this point.
So imagine.
Imagine if at that magical
moment, you take the user's
money and lose the purchase.
OK, let me reiterate this,
because this may
not be clear, OK?
You've taken the user's money,
and they've lost the purchase.
Now what does this mean?
OK.
This is not something you want
to do, and we work very, very
hard in In-App Billing v3 to
make sure you don't do that.
And also, as we roll out new
features for developers, we're
going to be rolling all of them
around In-App Billing v3.
So it's very, very important
that you consider using it.
What we've seen from developers
already is people
who have switched to In-App
Billing v3 have seen fewer
problems with customer service,
fewer cancellations.
It is absolutely working.
So please, please, please.
There is a session that has been
recorded here at Google
I/O. Unfortunately, it is at
the same time as this one,
otherwise I would tell
you go see it.
That you should definitely go
and look up on the streams.
It is a fantastic session, and
it includes this joke.
KOH KIM: So we're going to talk
about other ways that you
can make money on Google Play
besides virtual coins and
magic swords and all
this other stuff.
And that's subscriptions.
Now wait--
DAN GALPIN: Well, you can use
subscriptions to buy virtual
coins and magic swords.
KOH KIM: Sure.
DAN GALPIN: OK.
Just want to make that clear.
KOH KIM: I'm just saying,
instead of it being a one-time
purchase, right, what if this
user is like, hey, I actually
want to keep this item?
Usually most items only
last a day, right,
those experience boosters.
Now what if you can get a user
to be like, hey, I want to get
this 50% experience booster
til end of time?
Well, that's where your can use
subscriptions as part of
your in-app purchases.
So they can actually make a big
difference when done well.
And so we actually had a game
developer, Glu Mobile, that
has implemented this within
"Eternity Warriors 2." Now if
you see, what was very
interesting is-- let's say
subscription is in blue.
In-app purchase, just
like buying items
individually, is in red--
so you see, subscription revenue
is actually making
more revenue than their
in-app purchases.
So I'm not saying you
should do this to
every one of your games.
It obviously matters.
You've got to look at
your game, make sure
it's the right thing.
But I mean, it is also a
viable way to not even
increase, but at least continue
and maintain that
custom relationship you
have with your user.
Because once they open that
wallet, that's actually very,
very important.
It doesn't happen that often.
DAN GALPIN: And another
to thing to consider.
I mean, a lot of the complaints
that people say
about free-to-play games is
that they don't feel like
they're getting enough value
for purchases, and
subscriptions is a way to
kind of close that gap.
For the person who is a hardcore
player who knows
they're going to be playing this
game a lot in the next
couple of weeks, months,
years, you can actually
provide them ways of saying,
look, here's a way in which we
can give you extra value for
your money in the game.
And so I think it's actually a
very powerful thing for people
who wouldn't normally be buying
premium games but now
are actually looking at things
that are premium.
KOH KIM: So it's another
way to think about it.
Let's also talk about other
things, other payment options.
So we, as many of you already
know, we offer direct carrier
billing to a lot of our users.
They cover nearly 50%
of our user base,
which is great, right?
You see all these carriers.
They all have direct
carrier billing
implemented with the game.
And obviously, we're trying
to expand more as we go.
So if you're interested on what
the update on that is,
you can also go to this talk
on making money in Google
Play, which is tomorrow.
But then we also have
gift cards.
And yes, gift cards are only
available in certain countries.
I'm sorry.
We're trying to expand it.
There's many other countries
that would like gift cards,
because not everyone in the
world has a credit card or
direct carrier billing.
So we're working on it, but it's
just to know that there
are many options available
to users.
Because we care.
Users like to pay for things
in different ways.
DAN GALPIN: We like
to help users pay.
We do.
KOH KIM: It makes
your job easier.
So level four.
Global empires.
So how many of you have traveled
from outside the
United States and San Francisco
to get here?
See?
A very significant
portion of you.
Asia, Europe--
DAN GALPIN: This is a really big
room, by the way, for you
who are watching this
on the stream.
KOH KIM: And of course, everyone
that's watching our
livestream right now, right?
Clearly, there's probably a
good portion of them from
abroad who's not been
in the thing.
Well, what's great is
Android is big all
over the world, right?
And also, Google Play is
available in 130 countries, so
you should probably be doing
business with all of this.
So I'm actually living
in Korea right now.
I'm kind of doing some Games
work while in Korea.
DAN GALPIN: I thought
you were here now.
KOH KIM: Yes.
I'm here now, obviously,
but I'm visiting.
But in this case, actually I was
in G-STAR, which is kind
of this large video game
conference in Korea about in
November 2012.
And the way to think about it is
100,000 people, all gamers,
kind of like checking
out what's new.
What was actually really
incredible is that on the show
floor, 80%--
literally 80%.
There were some random consoles
that were still
there-- but 80% of the floor was
covered with mobile games.
And what are most of those
games being played on?
What devices?
Well, I mean, as you've
probably figured,
it's Android devices.
And what's great is because of
this, Google Play is actually
growing faster than
devices activated.
I don't need to remind you.
It's the 48 billion installs,
and a lot of
that is actually games.
And so that's great
for your business.
It's a huge opportunity,
right?
What are we talking about?
So at this point last year, we
didn't really talk about how
you can make money abroad
or all this stuff.
But I mean, this is probably the
time to think about how to
expand beyond your own market.
So for one thing is that I was
talking to my Korean cousin
about a certain game, and
she's was telling me
[SPEAKING KOREAN].
So you probably don't
understand
that, but it's Korean.
They were kind of complaining
the game was only in English,
and they'd like to play it in
Korean if it was available, or
asking me if I knew the
developer was going
to launch in Korean.
So what does that mean?
You actually have a larger
fanbase that could be out
there, and especially since some
of our fastest growing
markets are in Asia,
specifically especially Japan,
Korea, Hong Kong, Taiwan.
You probably should start
thinking about how I should
take my game kind of globally
or outside my borders.
So let's take an example of
"Gun Bros 2," which is a
pretty neat game from
Glu Mobile.
I mean, this is kind of like
what their page looks like
from the US or any
English-speaking territory, right?
So in January, we actually
launched the ability for you
to upload localized assets, so
screenshots, graphics, icons,
and banners.
And you can change
them by region.
So what does this mean?
Glu decided to create a Korean
version of their game.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, now it looks
like I'm going to blow things
up in Korean.
KOH KIM: Now imagine as
a Korean user how
excited you could be.
Because this looks pretty
cool, right?
Look, all the titles
are Korean.
That actually says "Gun
Bros 2" in Korean.
I actually think the title in
Korean looks a lot better than
the English version.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
it's awesome.
I want to play the Korean
version more.
There's something cooler
about that.
KOH KIM: So what
does this mean?
Well, if your user can
understand what this game is
and what it's about, it's
probably more likely they're
going to actually download
and install the game.
DAN GALPIN: Probably.
KOH KIM: So is it really
worth it, right?
I mean, that's a lot
of languages.
DAN GALPIN: Probably?
I think it's incredibly
more likely.
KOH KIM: Right.
Probably incredibly more
likely, right?
And so, how much more likely?
Well, let's talk about
this, right?
So we're talking about two
launches from Glu Mobile.
So they've launched two games.
One was "Eternity Warriors 2,"
and also the next game was
"Blood & Glory Legend."
They were
actually only a week apart.
They were launched in
about August 2012.
So the only difference is that
"Eternity Warriors 2" was
actually localized in
Korean at launch.
Meanwhile, "Blood & Glory Legend
2" was only available
in English.
DAN GALPIN: The icons
almost look--
You can't even tell which
game is all that
different from the other.
In one, I guess they wear armor,
and the other one--
KOH KIM: Has glowing eyes.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it's
pretty close, OK?
KOH KIM: So let's check
out what happened.
Obviously, a tale
of two launches.
So let's talk about Glu
Mobile downloads.
"Eternity Warriors 2" is the one
in blue, and the "Blood &
Glory Legend" is in red.
This is for Korea.
So you can notice that the
downloads for a game, because
the game was localized in
Korean, was significantly
higher than the "Blood
& Glory Legend." Is
that actually installs?
DAN GALPIN: Those
are downloads.
That's flatlining there.
That's incredible.
KOH KIM: But yeah, downloads
are great, right?
It doesn't matter if
they don't pay.
DAN GALPIN: Is this
in Korea then?
KOH KIM: This is
just in Korea.
DAN GALPIN: Just in Korea, OK.
I'm like, I hope they got a few
downloads in the rest of
the world, at least.
KOH KIM: Oh, yes.
I'm sure they did in other
English-speaking territories.
But I mean, the thing is, you
can get downloads, right?
That's great.
But will these users
actually pay?
Well, let's look at revenue.
Yeah.
So yeah, these users will pay
if the game is actually in
their local language.
DAN GALPIN: So wait.
So more users and happy users
means more revenue.
KOH KIM: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: That sounds like
something we said earlier.
KOH KIM: Right.
Not-so-secret formula, guys.
You always gotta think about
your user, right?
So it doesn't matter if they're
in Korea, Japan,
Russia, Brazil.
I mean, it's always nice to have
their game in their local
language, because then they can
actually enjoy it more.
It's all about the user.
That's what we're here for.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
KOH KIM: So let's talk about
another developer, right?
You've probably heard
enough about Glu.
We don't really care anymore.
Tell me about some
other developer.
So let's talk about
Gameloft, right?
So they've been enjoying the
whole mobile game revenue,
making lots of money, 190%
year over year growth.
By the way, data not really
reflective, but just to show
you percentages.
Now they started localizing
in Korean, right?
And so this is what happened.
Korea, all of a sudden, is
increased to 520%, just
because they started localizing
in Korean.
And now the Korean market
is actually one of their
fastest-growing markets
by revenue
within their portfolio.
And this is not just Gameloft
either, right?
I mean, we have publishers like
EA that have seen very
similar revenue growth lifts,
about 30% or even higher for
some territories that don't have
enough English speakers.
And tons of my other developers
as well have noted
that they're just seeing a lot
higher revenue, especially in
those markets, just for
being in Korean,
Japanese, or all those.
So what does this mean?
Well, so localization does
not equal translation.
Let me make that clear.
Localization does not
equal translation.
So what does that mean?
Well, you can do translated
strings, right?
That's awesome, but you've
really got to think about your
game, right?
Each market is different.
Each user is different.
They're going to be to different
ways of paying.
They're going to be used to
different ways of gameplay,
leveling up.
DAN GALPIN: And not every game
should be localized.
Look, I mean, if you're going to
be talking about the great
American sport of football, you
should figure out which
countries are actually
going to like that.
But certainly, there's a lot of
things that will translate
very, very well to a
global audience.
And that's what we're seeing is
that when developers take
the time to actually make their
game work for a global
audience, they get paid
back in spades.
OK, we're going to
move quickly.
We're almost out of time here.
KOH KIM: We've got
to move quickly.
Sorry, moving really quickly.
But if you want to find out
more, we're going to talk
about Korea.
We'll show it later.
But we also have an
awesome talk.
DAN GALPIN: We have a talk about
building Android apps
for a global audience tomorrow,
and a Play office
hours talk on Korea and Japan
Friday afternoon, where you
get to see more Koh.
KOH KIM: More me.
So next.
Quickly, quickly.
(IN UNISON): The bonus round!
DAN GALPIN: All right.
So how many of you have visited
our arcade out there
that we have out
in the Sandbox?
Like four of you.
Come on, some of you must
be game developers.
All right, all right,
a few more.
So we've talked a lot about game
controllers in the past.
We added support for standard
HID controllers in Honeycomb,
and it's been gratifying to see
a lot of games having some
limited support for them.
But here's the problem, OK?
I'm a gamer.
I've got "Nostalgic Racer"
which, of course is my
favorite test game that
we used to build
Google Play game services.
And I was excited to see that it
had support for a nostalgic
controller-- woo-hoo!--
so making gamers like me happy.
OK.
What this means is that you
should actually make sure
you're using defaults for all of
these things in your menus,
especially the Action button.
Because we kind of screwed up,
and I'll go into a bit of
detail about that.
So here's a generic
controller.
This looks like a controller
from any number of consoles.
In fact it turns out if you plug
in an OEM Xbox or OEM PS3
controller into an Android
device, it actually maps
almost exactly like this.
Not every third-party controller
will work this way,
because these are actually done
using Linux drivers that
have been contributed
from the community.
So we actually will map both
to the axis hat, which is
actually an analog axis, for
some bizarre reason, in HID,
and axis-x and axis-y into D-pad
events for you, which is
really, really cool.
We also map the x and y into
D-pad center, which is really
cool as well.
And we map A and B both to the
Back button, which kind of
sucks, because no one really
thinks the A button should go
back, not even us.
So what you should really do is
make sure that if you are
going to bother handling these
things, make sure to handle
the A button explicitly.
That's all this entire
slide was about.
All right, other
common buttons.
Make them do things.
All right, now other
common buttons.
Make them do things too.
And here's the final thing
I want to say.
You also probably want to handle
analog input, a lot of
you, because it's really
important.
A lot of these games are
designed around touch screens.
Analog input is important.
So we have analog axes, OK?
As it turns out, most of
these axes are going
to look like this.
You actually have to be a little
bit careful when you're
handling the two front triggers,
because they're
going to come in on
most devices, and
that's also hat switch.
Let me explain this quickly.
So if you're handling analog
axes, and you want to handle
D-pad events, you actually have
to make sure you handle
both D-pad events and handle
the hat switch.
Because what we end up doing
is bundling motion events
together, and if you say that
you're handling all of them,
we'll never generate D-pad
events for you anymore.
Because we're like, oh,
the game's got it.
We don't need to do those
legacy events for it.
So if you want to handle D-pad,
you also have to handle
hat switch.
And one more thing to note
on this is that if you're
handling the triggers, you
actually need make sure you're
handling both RTrigger
and Throttle and
LTrigger and Brake.
They will almost always be the
same thing, because it turns
out that most of the drivers
in the Linux kernel will
actually map everything to
Throttle and Brake, no matter
what the device sends out.
And as it turns out, the HID
spec mostly sends out
Throttle and Brake.
So unless you have an Xbox
controller today with the
current versions, you're
actually not going to get
LTrigger and RTrigger--
or a Shield device, I think,
will do the same thing.
But Throttle and Brake
are things you
want to handle together.
So think of these as being
synonymous for now.
At least your defaults should
handle them that way.
All right.
That was a lot of information
in a very short time.
But there's a lot of sessions
of interest you should see
here while you're here at Google
I/O. These are things
that haven't happened yet.
So we have "Android As Seen On
TV," which is going to have
some awesome use for
game developers.
We're going to have--
KOH KIM: "Building Apps for
a Global Audience," where
they're going to talk about some
of the APIs, some of the
new features that was announced
in keynote and how
you can implement that within
your application.
DAN GALPIN: "What's New for Devs
in Google Play," which
has got some super exciting
stuff going on, as well as--
KOH KIM: "Getting Discovered
on Google Play,' which I
actually highly recommend going
to, because it talks
about how that entire
magic box works.
DAN GALPIN: Finally, "Making
Money on Google Play," and
then "Make Your Game More Social
Codelab," which is a
codelab where you can either
bring your own game, or you
can actually use our game and
implement Google Play services
in your game.
And that is it.
Thank you very much.
KOH KIM: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]